- Hi everyone, Sal here from Khan Academy.
So for most of human history,
when we were either hunter
gatherers or early farmers,
we had a lot of time where
we would just look at things
and not be overstimulated,
there'd just be a bubbling brook.
But now we're constantly stimulated
by social media, by things
we have to do at school,
things that we have to do at work,
our cell phones ringing,
getting different text messages
and before we know it,
in modern society, our brains,
our thoughts are taking control of us.
And we actually don't have as much peace
and as much stillness as we would like.
And so one thing that I found in my life
is that everyday you take some time out
to just let your mind be still,
you start to observe your thoughts,
that it can be incredibly powerful,
it's going to improve your mood,
and it's going to just
make you a overall happier
and more functional person.